The Hollywood Reporter says that CBS is  looking into allegations of sexual  harassment against Emmy winner Jeremy  Piven he stars in the CBS drama wisdom  of the crowd in a series of tweets on  Monday actress area and Bella Mar  claimed the entourage star groped her on  two occasions she also said that he sent  her abusive explicit text now Piven says  I unequivocally deny the appalling  allegations being peddled about me  earlier this week a former staffer of  the CBS show Hawaii five-o sued the  network she says colleagues will  heatedly harassed her the lawsuit claims  a manager addressed the behavior but did  not punish anyone CBS is not commenting